ja irgendwie ist es wirklich verhext der
dunkle materie sie ist einfach nicht
aufzuspüren zwar können wir sie immer
wieder beobachten zb durch
gravitationslinsen also verzerrung des
lichts hinter der dunklen materie
es muss sie also irgendwie geben aber
noch kein einziges teilchen der dunklen
materie wurde gefunden und das soll
jetzt anders werden
ein forschungsteam hat jetzt einen
empfänger für die wellen dieser teilchen
konstruiert er soll den durchbruch
bringen jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
und verdammt noch mal das kann doch
einfach nicht sein wir wissen dass es
sie gibt aber wo ist sie noch kein
einziges teilchen der dunklen materie
wurde bisher gefunden höchst verdächtig
die wimps die weekly interacting massive
particles also die schwach
interagierenden massiven teilchen der
name liefert schon die erklärung dafür
warum diese hypothetisch also auf nur
vermuteten teilchen nicht gefunden
werden sie interagieren nur sehr schwach
mit anderen teilchen kann nicht keine
chemische reaktionen einfach nur sehr
sehr wenig wenn es sie überhaupt gibt
doch die für sie gibt nicht auf dort
kannten physik gibt es ja nicht nur
teilchen sondern auch wellen und zwar
gleichzeitig ein teilchen ist eine welle
und umgekehrt das berühmte doppelt spalt
experiment zeigt das ziemlich
beeindruckend lasse ich nicht durch zwei
spalten fallen
verhalten sie sich dahinter wie wählen
sie bilden interferenzen dahinter wie
wellen und keine schatten messe ich
dagegen durch welchen spalt die
lichtteilchen fliegen dann gibt es keine
interferenzen sondern die beiden spalte
werden dahinter projiziert also
abgebildet es sind teilchen die durch
die spalten fliegen also total verrückt
für die teilchen der dunklen materie
bedeutet dies dass sie nicht nur durch
teilchendetektoren gefunden werden
können sondern eben auch durch wellen
detektoren und genau den einen solchen
haben us forscherinnen und forscher
jetzt gebaut ein dunkle materie radio
die wimps die müssen sie eigentlich
durch die ihre gammastrahlung entdeckt
werden können die bei ihren kollisionen
entsteht bisheriges ergebnis 0 deshalb
wird jetzt nach leichteren teilchen
gesucht beziehungsweise deren wellen so
genannte aktionen oder dunkle photonen
also lichtteilchen die allerdings kein
licht transportieren ihre wellen sollen
jetzt selektiert werden an der stanford
university wurde jetzt der prototyp
eines solchen detektor entwickelt noch
kann ja nur in einem sehr engen
frequenzbereich suchen aber er soll
schon bald erweitert werden zitat es ist
großartig dass wir dieses neue
detektoren konzept mit einem instrument
ausprobieren können das relativ wenig
kostet und kaum risiken birgt das sagt
erin fips vom camel institute also keine
riesen technik soll ein ganz einfaches
instrument das so gar nicht mal groß vor
kosmischer strahlung geschützt werden
muss
das geschieht mit einer dünnen schicht
aus supraleitende materialien und auch
bei empfänger modul kommt supraleitung
zum einsatz in form eines supraleitenden
quanten interferenz gerätes es wird mit
einem besonders rauscharmen
elektronische verstärker kombiniert ob
es damit endlich gelingt die teilchen
oder wellen der dunkle materie zu
entdecken es wird spannend oder besteht
die dunkle materie doch auch etwas ganz
anderem
ihr werdet es hier auf jeden fall bei
klicks und science fiction erfahren mir
einfach ein abo aufs auge drücken damit
er kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpasst und nicht
vergessen den auf die glocke dann gibt
es nämlich immer einen hinweis wenn es
ein neues video gibt und hier geht es
weiter mit einer sehr spannenden käse
dunkle materie rätsel gelöst spielen
schwarze löcher eine rolle
unbedingt anschauen draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran